today we're making a chickpea carbonara
with shiitake bacon and crispy leeks
it's
it's delicious
and so the first thing we're going to do
actually drew i think your pot of water
should be boiling we're just gonna drop
in our pasta so we're actually using a
chickpea pasta which makes it gluten
free you can use any other gluten-free
noodle or you can use a regular wheat
noodle so that's going that's boiling
doing its thing so in my pan over here i
have some leeks
um which is going to be the base of our
sauce so i've been sauteing these leeks
until they get really soft and caramely
you can start with drew can start on the
garnish actually yeah so you have more
leeks you're going to make the the
shiitake bacon
so in this tray basically we're making
the topping the crispy topping so it's
going to be shiitake bacon and what that
is is shiitake mushrooms that we've
sliced fine and we've seasoned with salt
and pepper some olive oil and paprika
actually
and what happens is when you put these
in the oven you're going to go 375 for
about 25 minutes and the
uh mushrooms are gonna get really really
nice and crispy as will the leeks so
we're gonna walk these over they have
like a crispy and a chewy just like
bacon does and if you're a vegetarian or
you're looking to get more vegetables in
your week rather than meats and find
that balance as a flexitarian
mushrooms like are most vegetarians meat
that's why there's like a portabello
burger and all of that stuff too so the
garnish this is for the topping of the
pasta and we're gonna have that cool now
drew sorry about that earlier i jumped
ahead a little bit and i was talking
about the sauce that we made so
basically it's all these leeks that get
caramelized down and to this
i'm going to add a little bit
of miso and i do a little aquafaba and
you actually have the puree over there
already ready so what you do with this
sauce is you cook it down you simmer it
until all those flavors meld and then
you blend it so it becomes like
it becomes this very beautiful creamy
sauce
aquafaba is such an amazing ingredient
it's the water that the chickpeas come
in and it's really enriching to a dish
and then drew what i like to do over
here is actually just take a ladle full
of pasta water
into that dish
yeah um so this is a little bit of yuzu
juice yuzu is an
east asian citrus and if you don't have
yuzu you could also use lime it works
really beautifully and that just like
brightens everything up and so my sauce
is almost done and what i'm going to do
is we have some of the cooked noodles
over here
and we're going to pop those in
and you want it to feel like with most
like cream pasta is true you want it to
feel slightly over dressed you want it
on the wetter side because
as it sits and cooks that is basically
just gonna absorb all that beautiful
beautiful sauce all right i am ready to
plate mine up how are you doing over
there i'm doing really well
rebel homemaker it is not called i am
perfect and trying to pretend to be it's
called get it into the dish so i can get
it into my mouth
so i like to scoop a little bit more of
that sauce because i'll love it
i love that sauce and then we're gonna
do some chives
and then the beautiful crispy leeks and
bacon for that crunch
i'm just going in with my hands oh
i like that
all right little bird's nest there i
love it now if you want to get fancy the
special occasion ingredient that can go
on top is
a trout row or a salmon row also would
work so that little like pop
of goodness
saltiness
so so delicious and that beautiful color
i'm salivating right now shall we so hot
survive
i really taste the yuzu
it's so bright it's strange
something so comforty and creamy with
also an earthy mushroom base can be so
citrusy it's still really fresh right
very fresh and even up until the row the
whole dish is completely vegan and you
can make it completely gluten free so
just something to keep in mind
[Music]
[Applause]
this is one i truly love and it's really
you and me in a bowl absolutely never
said that before
um
this is so special
hello
you and me in a bowl there you go cheers
i love you
thank you so much check out our full
recipe on the drewberrymart show.com
from our cookbook rebel homemaker
[Music]